imagine experience interfere Oh imagine
actually spear is enough oh my god
that's like a one in a what is seven
billion chance of happening you
you guys so 30 is it that one si si
yes cheers guys well you guys you know
the drill
patreon YouTube's what if I Apple
podcast patreon twitter twitter [ __ ]
Tik Tok did you follow like subscribe
download everything I don't know yeah
man we're on every meet platform show us
speaking of tick-tock boy mmm talk to me
I love you a tick-tock you know why you
know why you can't DM people on
tick-tock tell me because Peter files
its [ __ ] kids on tick-tock well
there's kids eggs all up scroll through
today is that what you're about to say
sounds wrong all of scroll through all
of scroll through today is underaged
spices looking for dick pedophiles are
gonna scoop them up it allows growth
with today as kids on tick tock
basically straight true is addictive I
hate it there is big dick talk is so
addictive you just scroll and scroll and
scroll it's so addictive like you just
find so so many fascinating things on
there you actually do it so crazy it's
like every not just as you're getting
bored you're come across
wise as well once Oh tick tock his jokes
it's crazy because tick tock Instagram
vine snapchat not snapchat what else
whatever social media like geek I think
the Ordos video was that they were back
in a day yes like things like house
playing in that house white it's
basically night Skype but it's just like
a new version exactly does exactly the
same thing you play there all bro
they're all the same thing same thing
but they just have slight little
improvements on the on the last thing I
never was just gasps I wonder what the
new instagrams gonna be Oh instagrams
I'm about four
why instagrams been enough for a minute
Facebook's so done oh boy people use
Facebook more for business now than
anything else yeah okay well I think I
stopped using Facebook in - I'm good
with years
mm and when did I start delight 2015 I'm
neither 2015 2014 no 2013 13 mm 14 2014
so it's a waste of time
I'm sorry without malarkey yeah 2014 is
when to delete facebook or like um I
unsubscribe to it you know I mean just
delete it deactivate deactivate that's
what I'm looking for I need those are
what does what I do activate my cup yeah
man I've still got my brother and he's
if anything I think it's just hooked up
to the podcast one forecast page but
apart for that don't use it yeah I set
up up for that don't go the [ __ ]
podcast whenever it's made in just he's
bad that um stuff that we do for the
podcast like if I don't do it in my own
life hmm
I neglect it mmm I'm like the Facebook
page for example I'm terrible at 12 when
some days I'll be like did your ding
ding ding of the day that I won't even
remember exists I [ __ ] loved well
it's just so funny to me you're doing
you do you always send me [ __ ] from
Twitter is so funny to me [ __ ] I love 12
you guys need to follow us into a
prophecy you [ __ ] love you know what
I saw the other day that was I just
thought was so sick there was this guy
you know Chris D'Elia he posted on his
page evidence is completely out of any
sort of context but posted the thing
over there that like it was so cool it
just it was just like the perfect
example of like what like when you're an
inspiration to someone or like a famous
person or someone looks up to you or
whatever the actual effect it has on
that person yeah you know when you're
talking about behind the scenes of your
own story you there's this thing to
that's one you see in Christopher's
Instagram the other day see
definitely it's basically he found it
this one guy posted this long story I
was that basically saying how he woke up
in the morning he woke up in the morning
and he was feeling pissed off everything
and he says he listens to he just woke
up in a really [ __ ] bad mood we had
to get ready for work etc and usually
when he wakes up in a bad mood he
watches crystal his podcasts okay to to
feel better to plug him up for the day
and it'll go out but he said he had to
work so he didn't even have time to wake
up and watch it for work so he went into
work vex vex he said he was having a
[ __ ] day at work and then all of a
sudden crystally himself walks in to the
hallway walks into the thing and he was
like oh he was like was yeah he came in
spoke to me briefly we chopped up for a
minute or two and was really really cool
I got the chance to tell him that he's
the reason I started stand-up because
watching him live the life that he's
worked so hard
lived the perfect life that he lived
like so hard to achieve yeah to create
for himself he's an inspiration so he
chases the same dream yeah inspired him
to do this and that and he's like it's
very rare that you actually get the
opportunity to tell the one person who
made the difference to you that you did
they made the difference it was like it
was it was the best day of my life yeah
then Panta Christie D is actually
Instagram because he saw that video
mm-hmm posted on his page reposted on
his page yeah but he'd already posted a
video earlier that day of him in his car
and his own broth I walked into this
door today I've seen this guy yeah he's
like um I said to him bro you gotta eat
all the paper and he's like bro I'll
show it to you now
I'll show it to you now I'll tell evolve
so people can hear it if you want to see
the video Chris D'Elia
he's a comedian and he's he's he's funny
I don't want to play the other one
because it's just it wastes the whole
day oh no please and Toby's delete it
hang on oh yeah this is the one so
[Music]
[Music]
that's actually the sickest day yeah he
posted under the guys video yeah like
who knew just a simple trip to the store
yeah could be the highlight of both of
our days and I was like that's crazy
like it's crazy for that guy just
meeting him was the best thing that
happened to him yeah and for chris
d'elia
bump in obviously it was a cool thing
yeah it was just like a stick this
happened to me
there's like the difference in their
experience and the backstory I Kristen
Lee has no idea he's come in and out
just thought that was sick God move is
there a toilet paper but this guy's life
has changed because I revolved around
him bro I just looked at I was like that
is the sickest thing I've seen in ages
that's a coincidence mum she that
happens for reasons worth actually does
and now you said that was the day that
he didn't listen to Chris D'Elia on the
exact same day this exact same day he
couldn't wake up because he said it came
out it comes out because I listened to
it myself comes out at Tuesday's he said
he woke up came out that same day comes
it into work open it really [ __ ]
pissed off me to suicide me watch the
new one today and and then you thought
[ __ ] I've got worker current
and the my mom walks in firm that's
baniyas what that is bonkers I would
love that
why the odds of that it just all my days
you know what that reminds me of pop
what's it called the cat's thing was it
called don't [ __ ] with cats you loved
that [ __ ] thing don't ya don't forget
yeah it's to stop you documentaries bro
top three easy in like episode 2 when
they're in Germany or whatever and a
moment in the café's and cybercafe is
coincidentally reading watching the news
about what's he there a magnetar we're
watching news about him and then he
looks up and he sees him there that's
crazy
imagine experience interfere ah imagine
actually spear is in that oh my god
that's like a 1 in a 1 is 7 billion
chance of happening you're seeing on the
news about a guy that's a high risk if
he's seen please call the police
you own a cafe a cyber cafe you're
watching that you look up you're at your
next customer and he's the [ __ ] guy
pros on the [ __ ] news bro I would
[ __ ] myself
Oh screams [ __ ] scream what are your
areas you wait you're you think you're
you're part of it you think you know I
mean you'd think the stars of a line and
he's you're coincident his next victim
because that's my design 100% you think
he's come there for you 100% that's
exactly what because he see me he in my
head you know I'm gonna say he seen me
see him on TV so I know I'm dead do not
lean in your head he's watched you do
that whole Harvey huh all right now I'm
scattering the whole death what do you
mean I'm scaring the whole desks and
trying to get free I don't give a [ __ ]
about the shot so diamonds doesn't even
know what's going on he looks in the
window see some one guy goes or not I'll
go skips you paid it sir oh this oh cool
this is a dark twist
this is a steep turn but but what would
you do you like it's just music the fear
what would you do if you like if you god
forbid your walk you were just walking
down the street oh I'm like and the
night yeah and you see you literally see
someone raping someone you like you
actively see it and then you go like you
step towards them yeah they pull a gun
to you oh shut the [ __ ] up and then they
just dip just into the into the yeah
what the rapist runs away the rapist
runs the my girls just sitting there
trying to pull herself together
you've been victim you've been witness
to it threatened and then my tips it
just leaves me there with the evidence
yeah
what do you do I don't know cuz I feel
like if I call the police I'm gonna be
suspect number one do you know I mean
regardless of what the girl says wait
looks like
so the untrained eyes that I've raped
this girl of course I'm going home and
then to make it worse oh my god to make
it worse she didn't see his face
nah now I'm definitely going up she we
didn't see his face and she looks up and
she doesn't know if it was you or not
she didn't see this whole trouble [ __ ]
up thing she just was she was blinded
with mud and [ __ ] so the first thing she
sees me
the first thing she opens our eyes and
she just sees use time in there no no no
I'm going to jail regardless of why I
say I know I'm going Joe in the next
five days
oh my god imagine and she screamed at
something she's screaming so do you G
jump in and be like no no no wasn't me
this is what happened yeah would you
just instinct if you run I think my
instincts will tell me to run but then I
look more of a victim you do physically
course you do because when they do pick
you up and well why did you but that's
always the answer they are that's all
how did you person they ours is why did
you so why did you run if you're
innocent so why did you want because I
[ __ ] panicked
and that's you know what annoys me in
every movie ever they'll always say so
why did you run yeah you're innocent so
why did you run and then I don't know I
was scared you were coming I just
instinctively ran yeah and then I was
like yeah yeah yeah yeah it happens in
every single movie oh I'm sure face I
would run I would run
I'm definitely going to jail I would
just pray for some camera activity BAM I
would be so back and forth you what my
body wouldn't make sense because I would
run and then it will realize like no
she'll think it's me yeah and then by as
I inch back yeah my other side of my
brain is like rough now she'll
definitely think you've been running I
need you run a bit more you know I run
too far you oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's petrified and I just end up keep
running the fear in me will reboot and
reboot every boot and I'll just run in
and when I get home I'm like I won't be
able to sleep I won't be able to sleep
at night because I would think police
are knocking on my door in the next 24
hours
Oh every time you hear a car come past
is terrified and then the whole time
you're thinking why didn't I just stay
with her why didn't I just stay with her
why did I run you'll be thinking that
for weeks months oh that was scared they
live in Christ out of me oh yeah
cuz that's that's just so unfair
government is so and of course it is I
know that's when you hear stuff like are
they always return to the scene of the
crime you would end up going back after
you would yeah you didn't go back a
number like Oh typical
we're looking for a guy did did a black
guy here you are they always returned to
the scene in the car oh good you'll be
stomped front panel and then if they say
that to you say if they don't formally
arrest you but they're like oh we're
looking someone that meets your
description this is a crime scene you
know you're gonna buy it do you come
clean this is the thing are we
continuing to dig this hole are we
continuing to dig this hole you've
already run yeah you wish you went back
you've gone back yeah they say they're
looking basically for you and but at
this point you're not a suspect and they
say do you know anything about it and
this is your opportunity this is
actually opportunity to be like yes this
is why I'm here or keep your mouth shut
okay no way I feel like I've seen way
too many movies because if I say if I
opt in and try and help that's it that's
I'm number one suspect not because if
they take I will take you to the station
to ask you a few questions blah blah
blah I'm not leaving because that's what
happened to have you seen when they see
us when oh god yes that the first
episode when the when the the light that
it was not like you like the taller guy
like curly hair was he wanted to go with
his friend yeah to the station with you
and like he came willingly yeah yeah
when I didn't leave you got banged up
but he's banged him up in a room bro say
you [ __ ] killed him I'll say you bro
bro no no no if they say this they're
looking for someone that fits in my
description I'm walking away now you see
a thing sorry sorry
no because obviously going go because
what what what we see on movies in terms
of like that whole scenario happening
and that we voluntarily go to them we go
to them go to the station yeah yeah we
actually don't know what happens do you
know I mean because we only can go off
what we see - I can feel like that
happens it's true because I don't wear
company station so I don't know what
happens maybe it's true because I
subscribe to what they show us on TV Oh
number one I'm walking away then when
you okay cool so here's the thing oh my
god you've decided to walk away yeah
you're like Ike this is too hot now mmm
the things too hot and you walk away
you get ten steps and here just a second
mate mmm
the geezers running up behind you yeah
it was one of the police officers yeah
it's our sorry just really quickly as
you can understand as I said we're
looking for someone that definitely
meets your description or saying oh yeah
I don't even mean to come across rude
and would you do us a massive favor you
clearly live in the area would you do us
a massive favor and come to the station
you're not under arrest or anything just
come to the station a few questions till
it's not what you know about the area
tell us what brings you down past the
area today I that are your right to come
to the station within Li um you're under
no obligation or do you want to go home
I'm going home
what nah obviously feel so scared I'm
still saying about okay it was like if
you don't mind me what's the problem
there's been a rape is a serious crime
if you don't mind what's the problem
first firstly firstly he would never
tell me there was a rape that's happened
okay this is a serious see what this is
we're conducting a very serious
investigation there was a violent crime
committed here yeah just two nights ago
yeah if you don't mind me asking why
didn't you want to come to the police
station as I've said you know no you
know under arrest it's just for a few
questions because I'll say cuz I don't
have to okay because I don't have to
have no reason to go there so I don't
want to go there okay him he's like save
his eye
Oh me but the understandable and then he
he clicks his microphone it's like
there's no calming down me no I'm coming
down repeating or coming down and it's a
have a good day what do you do I'm
moving I'm quitting my job that day I'm
finding somewhere else to live I don't
know Mom
I'm done I'm done I know I'm going Joe
because the judge will ask me why didn't
I [ __ ] it when the judge everybody
when the police knock on your door mmm
and say if you had um we are officially
arresting you on suspicion of a rape
that happened two nights ago
mm-hmm
hey anything you say and do can be used
in evidence against you in a court of
law when you get down do you immediately
sad didn't do it no way for them to ask
you whether you ask me and when I wait
outright just a didn't do it okay cool
cool cool
so they take you in they stomp you get
my car they take you down to the station
they put you in a cell for three hours
then you go into interview room one and
they say we're just gonna ask you a few
questions about the rape that happened -
nice - go where you're walking and do
you want a solicitor or not were you
saying I feel like if I get unless he
said yeah they're saying it's just an
informal interview and you are welcome
to call your solicitor do you want to
close this and now I'm getting down for
you or not flush tricky that's tricky
I feel I feel like I'll say yes you'd
say yeah what was this are ya all right
cool and they're like okay then so we
asked you if you knew anything
what but you seemed a bit hasty like you
seem a bit worried liar or sup I'm
worrying because you've said I've
committed a crime that's why I'm late
I'm gonna stay all right cool so
scrapple this mmm you have you interview
direct cool they've already charged you
all this stuff you said you didn't do it
in the other stuff like that you get to
court
yeah and the judge says who had you've
pleaded not guilty but I can see right
here that we have eyewitness testimony
saying you were at the scene the crime
would you what do you say what happened
I'll explain the story again it's your
experience story again they say so why
didn't he help they go why did you run
away because I would explain the fact
that because she the first thing she saw
after the other guy run away was my face
and I didn't want her to think the
obviously instinct was a fight or flight
situation instinct told me to run cool
so insectoid you just so and then they
twist it and I all right cool so you're
Winston
isn't to help her newly raped victim
purest your instinct is to save her skin
and run and then that you see the
jewelry like and then he says second
point
why were you walk in there that day the
day the police saw you hmm
two days later why were you walking past
the theme I'll probably say I felt
guilty you feel guilty I felt guilty for
not helping her in the first place
that's just cool and then the other
lawyer says objections so cause you say
that the the cooperate always returns in
crime within two or three days and then
he goes overruled
and then they look at the thing they go
and then just sweating now
and he's like when the police asked you
to your face do you know anything about
it you said no food that was your chance
to come [ __ ] clean this is your
chance to say exactly what happened why
did you why didn't you say that because
I wasn't under oath then but I'm on the
roof now so I could have said what I
wanted to get home and then he's right
cool
perfect right you weren't under arrest
we had you said you went there because
you felt [ __ ] guilty for this girl
but when that asked specifically
specifically asked for your help in this
investigation that would have been your
opportunity to clear your conscience why
the [ __ ] did you still say no no that's
under and then from that's when you'll
go into jail for the rest of your life
she would just walking past the scene I
don't and cut you from congratulations
you've made yourself
gratulations you just played it just
made doesn't made the whole thing up
[ __ ] you know your mind wanders fun from
it does what would you do that holding
her
would you come clean from jump or would
you I would have I I would have liked
you but again I was walking past when
you saw a rape like I said I would have
ran and run background and ran around
back um I would I would stop call the
police I think my body would stop me
once I got around the corner or
something and I'm seeing a couple people
looking at me running or even if they're
not like I'm just I'm paranoia now I'll
be like [ __ ] so I think I would sprint
back while I'm sprinting back I will
call 999 just so she thinks something I
don't know I went to get my phone I went
to get help or something like that I
don't know but that's probably what I
would have done but obviously you you
can do what you want to do you're
entitled to to save your own skin here I
would help the victim I believe I don't
think a lot of people wolf um I'm
telling you that to be fair I think I
probably the exact same thing that's why
I was laughing sir no I did see at the
end of the day like I was I was at risk
as well like of course I had a gun to my
head
and we read whatever I shot the [ __ ] up
man so I feel like my life's in danger
so of course I'm gonna run Jesus what if
I spin it
what if obviously you did this back and
forth in back before thing but then as
you were running back calling the police
and you've really explained what
happened you get back to the scene and
the girls gone that's that's why I'll be
scared of that's what they'll be my
biggest fear is that I will sprint back
there and she's already gone baby she
definitely would assure diet
yeah you've given your name you've given
the location they've got your number all
of that
and your girls just can't the girls just
gone and they hang up do you like you
get back they go [ __ ] she's not there
any obvious you have to go home so I
wouldn't know if the police this is the
thing when the police are like stay
right there
yeah we'll be there I first when my body
will shake that's wrong what he was
shaking my eyes will roll I think I
don't do I stay or do I go I got myself
into what I need myself into a corner
what the [ __ ]
ah I just want this go home from work
long story short don't come across a
rape scene Oh God
oh my god Oh print home
[ __ ] I'm not making light of rape
it's a horrible crime but what I would
know I kind of I can what I would pay to
see that scenario I don't want to see
someone get rape yeah but the whole just
you walking like from to be a fly on the
wall to see walking in on a violent
crime I know like and as soon as you
gasps he's bringing a guy and then get
double like oh my god yeah and just
seeing your face skin and then him dip
in you look that's the funniest thing oh
my god that is the funniest thing I can
think of [ __ ] that's so crude ah Jesus
Christ that's funny
Wow I would crime-scene investigation I
was hate to be a number one sperms of
anything people get locked for murder
that they didn't commit all the time I
say all the time I don't know how often
it happens but found people get locked
for [ __ ] and they always plead innocent
so a couple is a matter fully innocent
oh snap what huh did you kick it down
yeah I don't think it might no it
doesn't matter okay it's fine um
thank God I say that yeah we'll see
mm-hmm
now but imagine oh I couldn't imagine
hubby you imagine me in pen pen pen coz
after that scenario you're in pen on a
urine pen and your sex you didn't to
help reverse place that's crazy that's
crazy that you have to pay for like we
live in a world not live in a world but
like the way we are designed is that you
can make a judgment a split judgment in
one second and decide to even run or
help yeah and no matter what
you do after that first initial reaction
you're [ __ ]
you are you [ __ ] it no and then you
have continuous more reactions where you
can either double down on your [ __ ]
doll I live like Oh or try and risk it
and go back scary that is very scary
well that's a very very scariest you
know I wouldn't wish that on anyone on
any me neither bro hot me the [ __ ]
neither imagine that I couldn't I
honestly couldn't imagine such thing
that's isn't that's a nightmare perv
I'm not going jail I couldn't go job for
anyone anyone yeah bro I'm not going Joe
because the thing obviously people in
jail find out what you go to jail for
and then imagine going to jail like
throw off the back of that and then
you're you're going to like lunch one
day in jail and they're like oh you're
like two room little girls now someone
comes ready now she's little male up to
rape you okay imagine I heard you like
to rape little girls little girls yeah
[ __ ] my balls would implode that's what
did do it
second of all I don't even I won't use
cuz I'm funny it's just [ __ ] Chinese
whispers plus you'd like to imagine -
you know like - radio goes alright now
we're going to seen once is seen to act
to a two-seam one you in pen yeah yeah
so right you're in pen and then man
rolls to you and says exactly word for
word in the dinner line you got your
tray he comes up behind you ear you can
he feared his warm breath on Bucky ear
and your neck you have pretty caught
your neck prick was up yeah and you look
back usually you as you look back he's
he's doubled scratching your nose there
he's here and he's got your shoulder so
you don't tiny buddy so you just turn
here in his hip and then he's like see
you wait like to my own little girls
yeah and then just lets go and walks off
doesn't even give you a chance to
respond just walks off oh my goodness
from I imagine no I know and then some
Mexican better next year is I calms
homes
that's dating from the Chenango brand
the eggplant is no joke
fam what do you do oh I'm dead broke I'm
dead man house I don't know man oh I
love to speak to the warden
okay cool inmate so you speak to the
warden and he's like yeah yeah yeah I
know who you are I know who you are
don't worry they're empty frets that you
said you said journey like cool water
can I get like solitary or something
ladies man will chat don't worry about
that yeah and plus you're a big strong
rapist you can handle yourself and then
God takes you down God takes you back to
the cup takes my jaw drop if you said
that to me God takes you back to
yourself yeah you're chilling there just
reading yeah and I won't be reading I'll
be shaking so won't be read it I'll take
it out for free I'll be there trembling
alright cool
[ __ ] so so and then you're trembling
you're trembling nothing's happened
you've not seen any of it and then like
yeah your nerves just about to start to
simmer down yeah just about
and then we managed to drift off I know
you're gonna say you managed to drift
off to sleep yeah and you wake up in the
middle of the night to take a sip of
water and you look and your cell doors
open wide the [ __ ] open and then you
you're stuck there all night and then
you can hear people giggling in the
hallway end of scene nothing happens
act 2 scene 2 you wake up you manage to
fall back asleep after hours you wake up
the gods banging on your thing saying
breakfast you have to go up and then I
call you up till like 6:00 you got like
an hour's sleep he says go up you get up
you have your breakfast
nothing happens you go back to your cell
BAE's done nothing happens again go to
sleep you wake up again sip of water you
look up doors open Donnie whispered
Donnie's in the doorway in the doorway
and says brother you've got a couple
options obviously you've done something
that's not forgivable if you can own it
with your chest and admit what you did
to me and how you did it I'll let you go
I mean what you did to me not to use or
it did to that little girl if you can
look me in my eye say exactly what you
did to that little girl yeah and how you
did it yeah or your alternative is you
can lie to me and say you didn't do it I
hate [ __ ] Liars so tell me exactly
what you did to that poor little girl
and how you did it and why you did it
and I'll let you go no harm will come of
you he looks that means you've accepted
your sin tell me what you did and how
you did on why you did it to her this
poor innocent child I'm gonna let it
slide lied to me in time you didn't do
it it's gonna be a long night for you
I'm not gonna lie what do you do so why
live a lie by telling him the truth
or tell the truth and get raped he says
he's gonna let it slide no even get
raped I did it and I say you did it and
you can't just say I did it you have to
say explain you have to say why you
wanted to rape a little girl you have to
say how you'll order in and did it you
ever tell him all of these details I'll
beggin I'll beg and plead and tell him
this the real story
I'll tell him exactly what all the judge
I didn't [ __ ] do it man he will be
like food had a Reggie case I read the
case file you have plenty of chances for
redemption this is your last chance for
[ __ ] redemption tell me the truth tell
me you did it or it's gonna be a long
sentence I didn't do it cuz I'm not I'm
not admitting that I couldn't admit that
you're black all right that's fine I
understand you were hard not to crack
that's fine
why don't I let the homies in hit run a
little train on you for a little while
and see if that loosens your tongue see
if you can get the honesty juices out
when Parker and Robin come in here Paco
Rabanne they come in there and sing you
a sweet little number from we're fightin
we have to fi in well final insolence
I've got no no more energy I can't I
can't bro I can't I thought I'm gonna
die within the first week I go to John
dying with Jesus [ __ ] hell that's
funny all of that's hilarious
oh because you just stumbled innocently
across a violent horrific crime and
that's the that's the only reason all of
this is just transpired Wow
and you're certain you're gonna fight to
your death but after that I can't admit
that I couldn't admit that I couldn't
admit I don't like some ice I couldn't
lie to them and say that I did that
you're true you're real man do you think
you passed you passed the test you
passed the test
yeah so we don't sister you redeem
yourself another variant you came back
in you man down you mind having your
fuse you refused to get raped and you
refuse to let these men wanna train as
you you just you you cut off every
option if I said no this is my
Redemption I'm not having it I couldn't
vote oh god that's funny and why the
answer no Jesus Christ that was amazing
good storytelling very good stories
loser
shut up right I didn't even read this
one Brier I saw the title for time okay
am I the [ __ ] for not one in my aunt
and cousin to live here despite them
facing homelessness my aunt and cousin
right so my mom made the decision on her
own to allow my aunt her sister and my
cousin to move in with us after she lost
her loft lost her job her home and
essentially became homeless she never
mentioned it to me and I'm not heartless
I understand what's going on but they
have been here for two weeks now and I
can't stand it the reasons I'm losing my
mind is because my aunt doesn't do
anything but drink and watch TV in the
living room all day where they sleep my
cousin who's 29 it's literally a couch
potato he's never held a job in his life
and has no plans to on top of that his
hygiene is [ __ ] terrible he refuses
to take a shower and it's [ __ ] gross
he wakes up at 7 a.m. and immediately
gets on his laptop into the 11 p.m. no
joke why this because he demands my aunt
to wait on him he's useless
I throw up what I almost throw up in my
own home because he's think so bad my
mom ignores this by locking herself in a
room and it's [ __ ] up it is not just
us for my boyfriend my brother his
girlfriend and their baby live here too
whoa these minor Asian say that my
boyfriend my brother his girlfriend yeah
here too yeah
what's that Asian hundreds an Asian no
no so she's asking if she's the [ __ ]
for not once in um
that's a tough one because obviously
morally they've done the right thing
yeah yeah yeah that's blood that's my
mother's brother or my mother's sister
sister and my cousin like morally
they've done the right thing but if
they've been there for two weeks and
they're doing that oh I'm checking them
I'm
hundred percent checking over MA and if
my mum is shying away from it I'm
locking herself in a room to avoid it
and I'm checking her to facts I'm
checking my mom because how how can you
how can you be so kind obviously to to
let them in is obviously a kind thing
but for them to ignore everything
they're doing in your house in your own
house wrong I'm checking my mom so she's
not no I wouldn't say she's an [ __ ]
I want to say she's always saying she's
also my [ __ ] them my that's that's
that's a piss take on her cousin rub
your skin rough and I yeah showering
that's wild but help and I knew I'd be
in a cocktail enough get nah if you're
not gonna pull your weight after I've
let you man stay here mmm even though
you are blood you need to do something
about that
mmm I'm right you need to find Sian even
me these times as well she didn't
mention it but this is like this isn't
just off the top of my head I hope while
she's right in that she has a look at
herself because clearly obviously she
said all my mom's obviously bought in
this like this person this person she
lives there with her boyfriend mmm she
lives there with her boyfriend so I
sincerely hope why she's checking it
that she's thinking like to be like I
hope she's got enough confidence that
she does everything that she can to
benefit the household yeah because if
she doesn't she's an [ __ ]
everyone needs to get the [ __ ] out leave
mom alone mummy stressed yeah my mum's
are paying mortgage she should be able
to look at and the brother's girlfriend
and their brother in the burbs
girlfriend I hope everyone in there's
put in their way pulling their [ __ ]
weight so help mum do exactly Mun
exactly wonder she's in a [ __ ] closet
crying drinking wine every night I'm an
hour running her running her wild fun
mmm [ __ ] my kid could never move in
with a partner in my house for what
never is never happening it's never
that's never gonna happen
did she never gonna happen this is mad
anyway
rappy yeah mum